[Musique]
ne bouge pas
laisse-moi voir ne bouge pas amy est là d'
accord
prêt
je l'aime c'est super gentil parce que
c'est terrible mon dieu
où étais-tu joel amy je t'aime
je vais venir te trouver
[Musique]
le jour du soulèvement des monstres
était le jour où j'ai perdu tout le monde
seule une petite fraction de l'humanité a
survécu et s'est déplacée sous terre
j'ai scanné amy tout le
temps
et maintenant je l'ai enfin trouvée
loin est la colonie d'Amy
85 miles c'est un voyage impossible
tout essaiera de vous tuer
ne vous battez pas courez et cachez-
vous d'accord toi tout seul moi aussi tu n'as pas à en
parler
tu veux venir avec moi
regarde-le c'est qu'un  épée de samouraï
ouais oui c'est écoutez vos
instincts ici mec et
si j'ai des instincts terribles
tu nous manques tellement
on a perdu cette laine on pourrait encore
prendre notre monde bac  k
tu es plus un survivant que je ne le pensais
euh c'était génial oh j'ai l'impression que
tom te croise